[Music]
so today we have an awesome topic an
awesome speaker so I will quickly go
over Karthik's byock karthik is a mln CH
leading the data science experience for
cue flow and working primarily on key
flow ferenc project before google
karthik was part of ML platform team at
uber self-driving team and also led a
team of data scientists in ubers risks
team he is passionate about making
design is productive having said that
I'll just do a quick plug for user
research so one of the things that we
say often in our meetups is this is a
collaborative forum we are here to
gather feedback from you understand your
pain points running machine learning
workloads so feel free to send us
feedback through a meetup channel you
can either post it on the meter page or
you know send us an email we are here to
answer your questions and also give us
feedback for the kinds of topics that
you want us to cover so going forward we
can make sure that we pick topics that
resonate with with your needs
that being said over to you colleague
Thank You Shannon no further
introduction hey how are you guys doing
good so today we are going to talk about
the notebook based machine learning
development I probably should have put
that but I put the project name that we
are going to talk about which is fairing
before kind of indeed using I want to
kind of give some context around what we
are doing in our team some my team is
cube floats a cube flow if we haven't
heard of before it's a it's a ml
platform based on cubed it is just a
kind of a raise of hands like how many
people have heard about Cuba deities are
used Cuban it is
it's good like a lot of people it's it's
quickly getting like you very like
becoming the standard de facto solution
to deploy your production applications
so think of what was her how do or yarn
was doing in like a kind of a ten years
ago similarly like Cuban it is this kind
of a resetting the the playing field for
like how you deploy apps and Cuban it is
proud native meaning it understands the
cloud environment it understands docker
so so with all these things it it's
quickly becoming like a much more easier
to deploy things at scale and what in
our team we realized is that with rice
of Cuban it is there's not much tooling
around machine learning for communities
and that's why we started this project
keep flow and cue flow aim of the cue
flow is to make machine learning on
Cuban it is much more simple and I'm
specifically talking about fairing
fairing it's very focused on making the
goal of cube flow work for data
scientist how many of here would
categorize yourself as a data scientist
or a machine learning engineer yeah
quite a few right so a lot of data
scientists out there they're not very
familiar with the infrastructure
technologies and rightly so like they
don't need to know about Cuban it is or
they don't need to know about me source
other infrastructure in order to perform
their duties so and especially when you
look at Cuban it is it's pretty has a
very pretty steep learning curve so for
a data scientist to spend that much time
to learn about Cuban it is and and in
ability familiarize with that it's may
not be the right kind of a impactful
thing for them
so so what we want to do is that can you
bring all this goodness of Cuban it is
into data scientist world and that means
like how we integrate with the notebooks
how we integrated a Python kind of a
style of programming and and when
talking about like a data scientist
environment so nowadays if you see like
Jupiter notebooks becoming like a kind
of the ubiquitous IDE for data
scientists there lot of lot more
languages not only Python like you have
our kernel you have a kernel now Swift
kernel like lot of new kernels are
coming up and the Jupiter notebook is
kind of a becoming a very good IDE for
data scientists so I'm going to kind of
show how we integrate with Jupiter and
give a like a very easy way for data
scientists to kind of build and deploy
models so before I kind of dive into
some of the architecture and more
complex things like I want to give you a
very quick simple demo that way you get
some context so here we are in a
notebook so so our fairing provides a
kind of a couple of different ways of
expressing your training logic so I'll
go by one by one and and and you can see
how it works so here I'm kind of using
this notebook but if you are not
familiar with this magic commanded it
basically saves this cell contents into
our file so I'm kind of a saving a
Python file called trained at PI so if
you this is an example but you might
already have a trained out pie that has
all your training logic right so let's
say like if you if you have that trained
at PI how do you go about executing it
so I will kind of a dive into like what
the backend is later but here you can
see that like I'm constructing a
training job out of this train dot PI
and I am just submitting that training
job so if I submit that job like ignore
this all this
logging for now we will connect live
deep into later for now what is
happening is that you know brief this
are trained at PI it's kind of packaged
into a docker container and shipped into
the cube flow cluster that I'm running
so I'm running a cuban entities custer
on GCP so we have a product called gke
which is like a google cuban it is
engine so where you can go and create a
clusters of your choice so I already
have a cluster that's running and so I'm
going to I'm running on top of that so
here you can see it just printed the
hello world which I wrote here it's a
pretty simple way how many of you here I
can never have their training logic in a
Python file okay typically you have it
in Python file
yeah good number of people like that's a
kind of the standard way it works with
gate so a lot of pieces that we see have
and even though like you have your main
training logic in a Python file you
still wants to use notebooks to kind of
a Schedule II a job and analyze the
output of your job so the second way you
can kind of execute a training job is
through a Python function so here you
can okay this is just a simple training
job function here this can be a very
complex function to you and it can
depend on other functions that you
define so this is very well-suited for
people who develop their machine
learning models in a notebook itself in
a notebook environment itself how many
of you kind of develop their code only
within the notebook not like switching
to Python file but within the notebook
any show of hands like that couple there
so so if we are having all your code in
the notebook itself so you can use you
can just pass that function that has
your training logic into the the train
job API oops I have to execute this
first nonlinear execution of notebooks
so you do that so
it's just a very similar job of
packaging that into a docker container
and executing that into the queue flow
cluster so as you can see we try to kind
of a not require the users to go go to
another CLI tool or go to another
dashboard to look at the logs or other
things but keep them within the
notebooks environment itself and kind of
provide you with that workflow so here
like we just executed the Train function
then we got the output here it cleaned
up all the things that it ran so the
other set of users I'm not sure I will
find it here but like a couple of our
colleagues at Netflix they're very you
know passionate about executing the
whole notebook so for example here I'm
trying to execute a notebook all trained
at IP and Bay let me open that so here
this is a different notebook so think of
this like you write the whole your model
development in a one notebook right and
sometimes that that behaves like a kind
of a report also so you train the your
model you you do some prediction you
brought some AUC curves you do some
model analysis right so let's say like
you wanted to kind of take that whole
notebook and execute it in the remote
cluster so that's possible too so so and
in order to do that we use a technology
called paper mill which is open sourced
by Netflix it's a way to execute your
notebook and parameterize and it's an
kind of a schedule so so far all these
other things that I executed doesn't
have a dependency so it was executing on
a simple Python based docker image now
in order for me to execute this notebook
I I need to kind of add a paper mill and
Jupiter to the requirements file so I'm
just creating a requirements file with
all my Python dependencies
so so we are going from how you specify
your training logic to how you specify
your dependencies so right now we
support a two ways of specifying your
dependencies the one way is to give a
requirement start text where do you add
your dependencies and the other way I'm
going to show is using a kind of custom
based container so if you already have a
base docker image where you all have
your dependencies you can specify that
those are specific a docker image it's
very useful for running it on GPU
because for GPU you need to install like
a CUDA and a lot of other things
probably your team or your company
already have a base images up that has
all your dependencies so that's a good
option for that use case and we are
planning to add a contour support in
addition to the the pipe requirements
how many of you here like use a pipe
corner yeah I think kind of equal in
numbers how many of you use kind of a
have they're all the dependencies
captured in a info docker file either
you created or your team provides very
few that's fine
so yeah like anyways like if you you
don't have to know anything about docker
in order to use the tools so that's one
of the main things that we wanted to
abstract out so here I wrote recommenced
a txt with paper mill and Jupiter now I
can kind of a execute the same thing the
only addition thing that additional
thing that I'm doing is that I'm giving
the input file which is the kind of the
all that your dependencies requirements
dot txt so now here you can see that it
tries to run that pip install since I
already did this it's using the cached
version of it so here you can see it
could have executed that that notebook
and prints out the kind of a non
graphical version of it you can also
save the notebook
and retrieve that notebook back so so so
far we have we done like able to kind of
a Swiss way what dependencies you want
able to specify how your training logic
whether it's in a Python file or a
Python function or a notebook now how do
you let's see how I can specify that
resource that you want so here this is
where like it's getting a little bit
into the kubernetes weeds but we are
trying to kind of this abstract this out
so you will you'll probably see a
battery API coming soon but for now
let's say like this is the function that
I wanted to execute it just prints out
how much CPU I have and memory I have
so this executed locally so it tells me
like I have 12 cores
with 32 gig ram so let me kind of
execute the same thing in a cluster and
ignore this particular syntax for now
this is where I talked about the kind of
very Cuban it is specific syntax so
basically I'm asking like a 90 CPU cores
and 600 gig memory so if I went go and
execute this so say it does like a
similar kind of a talker building step
but it's going to wait for some time the
reason it waits for it it's that it's
spinning up a VM with those requirements
so you know like no one wants to kind of
a keep spinning like a key keep those VM
try those are like way big VMs and costs
a lot so so we are using cuban it is
feature called Auto scale so if I go to
my Cuban it is cluster and Cuban is has
a notion of node poles the node poles
are kind of the pools of VMs that you
want used for your workload so so here I
created a node pool with a 96 CPUs and
624 GB RAM so so this node pool I set it
to auto scale so like the minimum size
is 0 and the maximum
is 10 so if there's no load on the
cluster it autoscale stat to zero so you
don't you don't pay for it so since I
executed this job it will create an
instance and start that instance and run
this workload so it will take probably
like at 3 or 4 minutes time so here's
some of the important concepts that we
covered right the entry point is like
what you how you want to specify your
logic you can specify your logic is a
Python file or a Python function or a
class we will I will kind of show you
the the Python class example later or
again if you want to exceed a complete
notebook you can execute it and when it
comes to a Python dependency management
we can either you can provide a base
docker image which is just very very
flexible right like you can install not
only a Python dependencies but also you
can install system dependencies like
CUDA or like other system components and
and if you don't want to deal with the
docker you can just give a requirement
start text file and we will kind of a
build docker ourself and right now we
have two types of jobs one is called
training the other one is on in
prediction the training is very simple
just takes your code and run it so we
have a support for distributed training
also will show that and for the online
prediction is where you train your model
and and you want to kind of put that
into an service where you can make a
HTTP call and get back the results so
this is useful for kind of a production
rising your model so once you have the
train the model if you want like a users
of your app or users of your internal
users they can kind of a hit this HTTP
endpoint then lastly I will kind of dive
into the the backends I kind of keep
that for now will we see that later so
let's see like what's happening to the
node that we still are waiting if I kind
of rough
so here I can see this like a one-note
started it's probably say where is that
it's so it's still not there yet
but that's fine it will come back little
later so diving into the cane of the
architecture and the implementation so
so we have three distinct a process that
we go through when whenever we schedule
a job so the first process is the the
preprocessor and and this is where like
how you specify your code gets packaged
say either you can specify it as a
notebook function or Python so so the
preprocessor handles that logic the
second step is the Builder phase and
this is where we build a docker image
out of that and here we have two we are
supporting like a multiple environments
where you are in right so for example
like you you you can be in an
environment where like a collab kind of
online hosted notebook environment or
you're running your notebook locally or
you are running your notebook in a Cuban
it is cluster itself so for different
environments we need different types of
docker builders so that's why ok we have
a couple of varieties of docker builders
not only just a local doctor builder but
also remote and will probably add some
cloud build support also so in the
deployer face is where we built the
docker image of your code and we wanted
to deploy it into a kind of a cluster
and that like the the job type matters
like for example if it's a distributed
tensorflow job we wanted to use a TF job
that's part of the key flow or if you
wants to do an online prediction we
wanted to do serving a type of job and
the one of the aim of this our queue
preparing sdk is that we wanted to be
very modular and extensible so so we
expose all this a pas to the inducer so
if you wanted to kind of a build a
different type of preprocessor for
example let's say like you want to kind
if I take a notebook and convert that
into a Python file and run that you will
be able to do that and also like for
example like if your company has a
different way of building docker
containers you can kind of plug that in
inside of that and on top of that we
what I showed is the kind of the Train
job API which tries to hide all these
Integrity's and and give you a very
simplified api where you just give your
Python file or your Python function it
goes and executes so one of the demos
that we have is the XC boost training
and deployment so here we have an extra
boost training so all these cells are
like pretty standard cells like here I'm
kind of a reading a sample data set and
doing some mutation like a kind of
replacing nulls with some mean values
and and here I'm doing like a very
simple fit this is nothing interesting
it's just like trying to showcase how
you do actually boost training and the
both the eval and the save or T simple
like I'm saving to a local file so so
and one more thing that we we are
exposing is nfn python class interface
where if we wanted to do both training
in prediction so you can follow this
interface where you have to have a
trained method in a predict method first
look let's look at the Train method and
see what it does so the Train method
reads the input converts that into
number arrays and train set model with
an umpire race and does eval and save
and in the predict method ignore this
feature names for for a moment that's a
kind of extra things that may not be
clickable here the main one is that you
get at and if an umpire input and you're
loading the model that you saved from
the training and you're doing prediction
on that numpy input and returning the
prediction so here I'm just returning
the same prediction just for example so
if I wanted to kind of a run this
training job locally I will just say the
house trained or trained right how's our
train here like it's a pretty simple
model so it's X it's pretty fast so
typically data scientists they want to
paint over train locally with a smaller
data set before training it on a bigger
data set so so that they the ideations
speed is much faster right so so here I
did that I trained locally it works so
now if I wanted to kind of do the same
thing on a remote cluster I I do some
configurations where I configure my
where I have to store my daugher widget
like a output docker files and also kind
of out creating a Python base image so
all these are defaults I'm just showing
it but you don't have to specify this it
will infer that automatically so so we
are going back to that train job API so
before we gave our Python function so
here we are giving a Python class so the
train job will take the Python class and
package that into a docker image and
execute it in the remote cluster so you
would see a similar experience so here
we are also giving a requirements dot
text so this one contains all the pandas
psychic learn all your requirements so
it's going to install all those
requirements for you in the docker image
so it takes some time to install that so
once it's installed it's going to push
that container to the remote docker
registry
so let it go so in terms of frameworks
right now we are supporting like a HC
boost and like GBM and we have support
for denser flow in a single node by
touch
just show our fans like how many people
here use kind of extra boost or like GBM
before they work like more like a
tabular data right like do you have and
and one more thing I wanted to kind of
her here is the kind of the feedback
because we are doing this in open source
and we wanted to kind of make sure that
it's useful to a wide range of audience
and not biased by like either internal
Google use cases or our customers so one
of the things that I will show you is
kind of a distributed support for like
GBM for the people who raise their hands
like how many people have a requirement
for distributed training for XE boost
are like GPM or like a single node
training is like fully sufficient so you
so you have a requirement like it can
you kennefa and like a ballpark like
like talk about like how many what cause
like you typically use or how long your
training goes it's an order of dozens of
workers and the training typically runs
for like 72 hours or so should be simple
enough for it we'll give it a try so so
here yeah it's pushing the docker image
here say since I kind of cleared out all
my cash it's rebuilding it when you
typically do this second time it should
be very fast
so yeah the it did run and it's very
similar to the local running it's pretty
fast so that's not much time to wait
for it running so and the other one that
I wanted to kind of a show is that how
to do a prediction so so going back to
the the class that we had said this
predict method right
so this predict method you can call it
locally but if you wanted to kind of a
put it as a HTTP service it takes a lot
of effort to kind of a package that and
ship it right so we wanted to kind of
simplify that process so here instead of
a train job you say I need a prediction
endpoint and you give the similar
arguments like you're the Python input
class your requirements one more thing
that you hear you are giving is a
trained model from your train from your
previous training and that's it so if I
execute this what it does is that first
it packages your Python class in around
HTTP wrapper so we use a library called
Seldon which is another popular open
source framework for doing online
prediction so since I built the docker
image previously this thing came up
pretty fast so it's waiting for the
endpoint to be created this will take
probably I get 10 to 20 seconds for it
to happen so then once the endpoint
comes back so you can do some you can
take an numpy array and do prediction
against that endpoint so so let that
happen
the when talking about the distributed
support like we have a support for
distributed training for allied GBM so
right GBM is so yeah so this we got an
endpoint where it says like a kind of an
IP address and port and a path so if I
go ahead and do the endpoint prediction
it basically calls that numpy array
against that HTTP endpoint and gives
back the results
so there will be more like will improve
the APA to be more easier to use like
probably giving back a panda's data
frame is much better use case and you
can go ahead and delete that in point if
you want homie so what you developed
here essentially acts as a wrapper on
top of sexy boost right or like GBM so
why is it not more generous to any other
model like CAD boost or random forests
while
why are you limited to XG boost or like
GPA for single node training that's a
great question good observation yeah
like if I were to Farah place the
question right like whatever I shown
here seems like a generic rail like
executing a Python file executing a full
notebook and executing a Python function
why it has to be constrained to X you
boost actually it's not like the demo
that I'm showing is actually boost but
you can put whatever you want like it's
not even ml related for now the one
thing that is ml related and and and
framework specific is the distributed
training part because for the
distributed training each framework
requires a kind of a specific set up for
example if you are doing a distributed
training for tensorflow
it needs specific environment variables
to be set up if you're doing for extreme
boost there are a couple of ways to do
it some needs like kind of MPA kind of
systems to be set up so so we are adding
a framework specific support for the
distributed learning but for single node
training you should be able to use any
framework you want the other one that we
are kind of a so what I showed with the
extra boost is where it's a Python API
right so you're kind of using the Python
XC boost API for for like GBM we
went ahead and did a kind of a native
integration with the CLI version of the
API so I will show that so a lot of
times especially for like GBM the lot of
features that are exposed as a CLI
that's very useful so they wanted to
kind of see a lot of uses they want to
kind of reuse the CLA version and here
we did a kind of a very native
integration where so this is the config
that that you typically use to trainer
like GBM model like this is similar to
an extra boost model thing right like so
you have a because unlike tensorflow
models the model architecture is pretty
fixed so you have only you control only
the hyper parameters so so here I'm
giving all my hyper parameters or
configuration for the model and here the
input data and and the output data all
specified as a GCS path so GCS is our
Google Cloud storage kind of a takes
care of all the storage for you so and
the users just go ahead and do like a
like GBM gotta execute like let me kind
of go through this run this process Oh
actually I don't need to do that one
because they already built that
container
so this so here it's much more native
integration towards like GBM where
you're not controlling like NFI you
don't have to build any specific Python
class or wrapper you just give this
configuration file and we are going to
execute like GBM with that configuration
file the one interesting part is that in
order to go from a single node to a
distributed node in like GBM you just
change a one parameter so I will show
you the distributed version of it
so here the like GBM itself has a
parameter called number of machines so
you change that to like a here 3 or
whatever you want
and and
when you exclude that with that
parameter we allocate that many workers
and do the distributor training so so
this is where like doing kind of the
framework level support is very useful
and very fast so and what what we have
seen is that specifically for like why
we chose like GBM specifically said you
know benchmarks like we like a scaled up
to like a terabytes of data and and it
gave like a pretty fast results and
closer to linear scaling so that's the
like GBM one let me try to see and here
are oops
okay so again here you can say like how
resourcing is pretty easily like you can
say like how many curves you want how
much memory you want and if you say like
a stream log is equal to true it will
stream the logs but if you say stream
log equal to false we can probably
easily put a for loop on top of this and
do very basic hyper parameter tuning so
you can if you have like it in hyper
parameters you can gain to go through
that pretty simple and and all the model
outputs are saved into a specific GC
spot so you can can defer go go back and
retrieve that files so let me see if I
can execute this part so all of this are
happening with autoscale enabled so so
if we go back to that your the cluster
scales automatically whenever you
execute a job and and it goes back when
you don't but this seems to be either
some problem where it says like my parts
are not scheduled probably I'm hitting
some limits or something
so let me show you the another APA so so
similarly like we have a separate
support for tensorflow
distributed like if you want to do
tensorflow distributed so here's an
example of a simple amnesty tensorflow
based on the TF 2.0 api so here we are
using Kara's and the new distributed
distribution strategy and and here I'm
using this kind of the lower level a
place that I talked about just to
showcase how flexibility is right so I'm
doing I'm constructing this preprocessor
and I would recommend like this lower
level API for people who are very
familiar with cuban it is and they want
to control kind of the each step of the
process so you can kind of do the
pre-processing first then you can choose
what builder you want it to use like if
you if you want to use a key local
docker builder you can use this and so
we have a TF job API where you can say
like I want like a worker count 3 I'm
not using the parameter server style
training so I'm just putting the chief
count is equal to zero and if you do
that so this is things still running
it's completed so basically like you can
do kind of a distributed training with
this API so we are adding more framework
level support for example we'll be
adding a PI Taj distributed by touch
support but first and also X you boost
distributed excuse support also there's
a question
hoorah what you can use it it's little
bit tricky but it's you can do that like
with that low level API ApS you can do
that there's nothing preventing you yes
yeah
the auto-scaling everything is really
done my question is about high priority
ring so I was wondering if you wanted to
integrate like retune or github would
you do that at a level of calling you
know fairing functions directly or would
there be a trained job at the API level
rephrasing the question like how do we
go about hyper parameter tuning like AB
and you mention about catty I I don't
know about the rate tune I'm not
familiar of a bigger project or it says
okay it's part of their a project right
so we are working on a better
integration with Khateeb so for example
if you take this the current API and
write a for loop around it it works but
it launches all the jobs at once it
doesn't kind of do the cube based
training or if you want to do a liter
mination
or do Bayesian optimization you can't do
it so we are in process of integrating
that with Khatib since Khatib is a part
of cube flow we are planning to
integrate the API would probably look
like something like that same will keep
the Train job API but probably you're
passing in a kind of a map of parameters
that you want to sweep so from your
perspective you're just launching like a
one job but but it will be translated
into multiple jobs and the parallelism
on how much trials you want to exceed
it'll be controlled by a tip thank you
for special I have a question so cube
flow and m/l engine are they supposed to
interchange and so are they same on the
same
how do they come together so we have the
the rephrasing the question like what
said how to platforms like Q flow and ml
engine which is our managed platform
like we recently rebranded as a a
platform so how does that compare I
would say like it's a two different
offerings based upon your requirement
for example q flow is fully open source
like Apache 2 license you can run it on
Prem you can run it in AWS but you have
to manage your communities cluster ok
GCP provides managed communities but
there's a lot of things that you have to
manage on top of that right like
creating node pools creating your
ingress services things like that so
it's about like whether you wanted to
kind of a take care of all those
management by yourself or you want to
have a much more cleaner API where you
say I just want to run this job I don't
care about cluster or I don't care about
life ii just run this training job and
give me back me output so the a platform
is much more tuned for that kind of a
managed offering yeah from-from pricing
point of view also we it's actually the
same like even in ml engine you just pay
for what you run
it's the GCP pricing this DC pricing so
I think people prefer like if you what
we have seen is that if your need like a
very good customer eyes ability like if
you really wants to have access to your
clusters you nodes probably queue flow
will be a better solution but if you
don't have a DevOps a team that can
support you ml engine is a much better
solution any questions
let me open this
so since we talked about cute flow that
means let me see the other one if that
yeah so so this one ran though remember
the one that we ran with Jennifer 90 CPU
and 600 gig memory so that ran and
printed like it has 96 CPU and 614 the
reason why this is 96 and and we asked
for 90 is that the node that it's
running it has 96 CPUs so it's printing
that 96 they came Cuba Cuban it is
usually schedules with the node like it
that's at least 90 CPUs so this one has
96 CPUs and if you wanted to kind of do
the same thing right like going back to
the simple example if you want to do the
GPU one like this and again this is
really little bit Cuban it is specific
syntax we will probably have a better
API soon so here I'm just going to print
out the GPU architecture here so again
like if I ask for GPU it kind of goes
and spins up the node and and runs this
process but since I already kind of
running this process before the node is
still alive so kind of it prints the the
v100 GPU that you have so so this is
another example of how you can optimize
your cost structure right so so
typically like if you wanted to train a
model with the GPU you go and create a
VM
with a GPU on it you you you execute
your model but a lot of time you spent
on analyzing your model or looking at
your data at the same time the the VM is
keeps on running right like that's like
a lot of money to pay typically people
shut down the VM and kind of move the
data out of the VM to their local box
and analyze the data but again that's a
lot of back and forth data transferring
and and a lot of hassle
so with this STK what you can do is that
you can kind of create a very small VM
instance with just a CPU few CPUs and
you can do all your analysis model
analysis and visualizations but when it
comes to actually training GPU you can
just schedule it on the remote cluster
which Auto scales to your workload so
essentially you're using the GPU nodes
only when it's needed and shutting it
down when you don't need it and and
since it's bringing back the results and
the data for you you don't have to
manually transfer any data sets yeah
this is like a similar example where I
run the EM nest model on the GP owns I
think yeah what I was so if you want to
get started I would suggest like going
to the cue Pro website so we have very
good documentation on how to get started
so one of the ways if you are GC like
this like a DCP doc AWS an on-prem even
Microsoft Doc also so if you go to GC p
we have a nice UI where you can spin up
a cluster so if you go to deploying
using UI very so so we have an app to
deploy q flow so there you specify your
project name in a couple of other
parameters so you have documentation on
how to fill this form so and when you
click create deployment it will create a
Cuban --'tis cluster for you and install
q flow on top of that then you can go to
that chip flow cluster you would
probably get a URL at this end of this
installation I'll go to my already
installed cluster
so this is the cue flow dashboard you
will get so here it has like a couple of
components I will go through like one is
the notebook components so you can
actually host a notebook on the cluster
so you can say I need a jupiter notebook
with this many CPUs and you can specify
like any GPUs you want like with extra
resources like nvidia gpus and it will
give you a kind of a link that you can
use it as a hosted notebook and also
this is the cat if that we talked about
which is a tool for doing hype a
parameter tuning and and here you can go
through go through creating a study so a
study is basically multiple experiments
that you do and kind of find out the
best one you want some time loading the
dashboard yeah so here you can go in and
kind of fill this form so this is the
current AP that we have so again like
this is not a very efficient way of
doing it like doing a lot of experiments
you don't want to go and create it
manually but also the other way is that
writing the samel file again it's a
little bit learning curve and not a very
good interface for data scientists
that's why we wanted to integrate this
API into the faring API where you just
give a Python map and we go and search
through all those hyper parameters the
another big product that we have is the
cube flow pipelines so once you did all
your training and experimentation now we
wanted to put that into a production
pipeline you can use this cube flow
pipelines product I'm not going to go
very deep into that but like it
generally explaining your machine
learning pipeline has multiple
so here we have like a training
prediction model analysis things like
that and you can create like a
production grade pipelines using this
product so Q is kind of a big ecosystem
has a lot of tools and firing is one of
them yeah so there's a very strong
connection between tf-x
and Q flow pipelines so T I think of
like ATF X is a pipeline component for
tensorflow specific things and q flow
pipelines is for all frameworks but we
have very good support of executing T FX
pipeline in Q flow pipeline actually
yeah like all my notebook that example I
shown is running on my local laptop so
so when I kicked edge off it was going
to the cluster so actually you don't
have to do much change out if I go back
to my previous example right so let's
say like you're executing this Python
function like this train function let's
say like if you wanted to do it training
locally you just have to do this so and
if you want to do it remote that's the
two lanes of core not much change you
can do it that way it also supports a
way to build docker image in the cluster
itself so you don't have to have a
docker
install on your local machine so the
darker build happens with with the
requirements that you specify right so
here you're specifying like these are my
Python requirements so it takes a
vanilla Python docker image and installs
those dependencies so so whether you
build the docker
image locally or in the cluster it's the
same thing so so in the stranger bapa we
don't have the number of nodes parameter
yet I so so this one is just single node
it's a single no training wheel like
it's - change will have that the one
that I showed the distributed training
on is using that like GBM API and also
the kind of the internal API but we will
expose that externally so right now we
will add its own like it's it's probably
coming next week so then you can specify
in addition to the number of CPU number
of GPU then you can specify number of
nodes you want to do yes the elasticity
comes from the kubernetes feature not
the fairing so in cuban it is if you go
and create a cuban entities cluster so
here are so so if we can see that one
machine that i had the very big machine
it it got terminated right now it's zero
nodes so here i turned on auto scaling
and set the minimum size to zero so so
then it like it will automatically do
that so that's a feature of cuban it is
itself so if you wanted to add model
versioning to different models that you
run strange jobs where would you add
that would that be at the level of a
docker container or is there some higher
level feature will be available that's a
very good question right now I'm solving
it in a very happy way if we go back to
my thing I'm just adding a timestamp to
my model output feature but there's one
more project called of metadata let me
kind of a
show you that so so this we've been
saying like this is a big issue right
like when people train multiple models
they want to kind of track and analyze
hyper parameters and unless models right
so this Q flow metadata is another
component of Q flow that's useful to
capture the metadata about your training
job like how many layers did he use
where is your model how much accuracy
you got and finally able to bring back
to your notebook as a panda's data frame
and able to analyze that so this is very
like a much more earlier stage but you
will probably keep watching this you'll
hear back soon yeah so right now we have
to do it manually
the couple of profiling information you
can get like for example like if you
wanted to get a model performance the
best tool would be using a tensile board
so you write the tensile Borlaug's we
are working on a easy ways to launch it
and sell for like one idea that we have
is when you launch a training job you
will get a URL for tensor board you can
just go there and see it but if right
now if you wanted to like a monitor
system matrix if we go to the job name
so so usually that spits out a job name
and if we go like right now it doesn't
have the data because the job is
finished but usually you will have CPU
disk and other things for you to monitor
but yes everything and and the the
feature of the kubernetes itself like if
there's something wrong with the pod it
will restart it and and going back to
the model monitoring selectively you
have to look at the tensor board and and
terminate there's a sitting in
tensorflow itself to do some early
termination it's not very advanced but
you can do that
so so that's a pretty cushy I will kind
of show you another thing we're touching
upon this particular aspect so you can
actually run a tensor board instance and
point that to a GCS bucket and you can
get all your training logs in to the GCS
bucket so for example I will show you a
tensor board that we are running
so so that way like you can you should
be able to see multiple runs
some issue but there's a feature where
intensive or let's say that you you take
a Jesus bucket and for every run you log
into that particular bucket so then in
the tensor board you should be able to
see all your experiments and compare
them yeah so see so when you do a
distributed training the all the notes
like training just one model right so so
typically you only write in surfboard
locks on from one node and so I think
it's not required like you typically
like you have the information on the
model performance on all the nodes so
you just take like one node and write
out the performance metrics from one
node that's sufficient any more
questions I'll be here so feel free to
ask any questions
Thanks thanks for attending
[Applause]